I can't I can't speak for it
[Music]
even just the actual flirting is
infidelity I wouldn't consider that
flirting but I consider that like whack
like if you're gonna do your power
lifting me right and then the Federation
is like I think we might pull out of
this event and then Bart has to go
are you sure maybe consider are you
gonna be honest you're not gonna be like
the team no I don't
know I have one I have to save my family
okay there's only one word account now
sleep with me because you might be
considered whack yeah
yeah wow
I'm gonna die now you're in the back
with the kids you're [__] whack yeah
I just want you to know that [__]
you're wow